Маленькі Роман і Поліна приміряють своє різдвяне вбрання.
Його власноруч пошила мама Наталія.
І будуть такі колядники, вже в неділю підемо колядувати.
Буде Поля колядувати? - Так.
Дітлахи вже розмалювали різдвяні зірки й вивчили колядки.
Ми прибули, господарю, до вашої хати.
Хочемо вам, господарю, заколядувати.
Наталія зізнається - для неї Різдво з дитинства було таким собі
казковим святом, головнішим за Новий рік.
Ту ж саму різдвяну магію хоче передати дітям - навіть у часи війни.
Прикрасили ялинку, постіль навіть новорічну купила.
А в душі нема такого, як от свято, всі радіють…
Так, радіємо, свято, красиво, ялинка, але на душі воно все рівно через ту війну...
У мене брат на війні...
У цій родині готуються зустрічати Різдво 25 грудня вже вдруге.
Наталія каже, що перейти на нову дату було нескладно.
Я, чесно кажучи, навіть не розумію трошки людей, які не можуть перейти.
Бо взагалі в Україні Різдво так і святкували, це ми вже забули,
так нам це перемішали. Новий рік перекрив те Різдво дідом морозом
і снігуркою, що й позабували, що так ми колись і святкували Різдво
дійсно з 24-го на 25-те, і це були такі класні традиції.
Востаннє на українських землях відзначали Різдво 25 грудня у 1917 році.
Нині ця дата знову стала святковою.
Цьогоріч Україна вперше офіційно відзначатиме Різдво 25 грудня,
як і значна частина православних церков на Заході.
Верховна Рада визначила саме 25 грудня державним святом - замість 7 січня.
На вулицях Києва можна почути різні думки про нову дату Різдва.
Я вважаю, що нам досить вже тих традицій, які були нав'язані.
І треба вже давно перейти на традиції світу і святкувати правильно,
по календарю, де 25-го Різдво справжнє.
25-го. - 25? - Сьомого.
У нас так в родині прийнято - в родині святкую 7-го.
А з друзями - можу і 25-го привітати.
Анна, яка виїхала з окупованого Енергодара,
цьогоріч опановує нову традицію.
Ми також будемо тепер 25-го святкувати.
Той рік ще святкували і 25-го, і 7-го січня.
А цей рік тільки так.
Студентка Габріела приїхала зі США в Київ на Різдво
разом зі своїм хлопцем-американцем.
Колядки? - Лише англійською. - Так, лише англійською.
- Але ми "Ой у лузі" вже почали - "Червону калину".
Я завжди підтримувала, щоб у нас було Різдво 25 числа також.
І взагалі мати два свята - і 25-го, і 7-го - це круто. Чому б і ні?
За опитуванням компанії Deloitte, 45 відсотків українців
відзначатимуть Різдво 25 грудня. 17 відсотків - 7 січня.
А третина українців планують відзначати Різдво двічі.
Цей храм у квітні 2022 року перейшов з УПЦ,
яку пов'язують з московським патріархатом,
до Православної церкви України.
Тепер церква збирає кошти на дрони й автівки для ЗСУ,
а питання переходу для громади було майже однозначним.
Ми голосували, ми ставили на голосування, і більше 70% громади
минулого року проголосували за те, щоб святкувати
Різдво Христове саме 25 грудня.
Торік у цьому храмі ще святкували Різдво двічі,
але цьогоріч - лише в грудні.
З 1 вересня 2023 року ПЦУ перейшла на новоюліанський календар.
Це вдосконалена версія юліанського календаря.
Нерухомі свята, прив'язані до конкретних дат, змістилися на 13 днів.
Юліанський календар запровадив Юлій Цезар.
Згодом з'ясувалося, що він неточний -  був неправильно обрахований час,
за який Земля робить оберт довкола Сонця.
Тож кожні 128 років накопичувалася доба розбіжності
між календарним і справжнім, астрономічним рівноденням.
Тут більше математична проблема, є похибка в тринадцять діб.
І математики, вони не могли з цим змиритися,
що в нас кожний рік по цих секундах набігає.
І якщо ми візьмемо уже 2100 рік, то тоді вже не 7 січня,
а 8 січня потрібно було б святкувати Різдво.
Папа Римський Григорій у 17-му столітті виправив цю похибку
й запровадив григоріанський календар, яким світ послуговується і нині.
Але низка православних церков продовжувала
жити за юліанським стилем.
Разом із ПЦУ з 1 вересня від старого календаря відмовилися
й Українська греко-католицька церква.
Календар, яким користуватимуться, в УГКЦ називають
не новоюліанським, а григоріанським.
У часи повномасштабного вторгнення настільки велика,
виразно велика більшість громадян, вірних нашої Церкви,
одноголосно заявляли, що вони хочуть зміни календаря,
тобто у єпископів, в синоду, з'явилося повне розуміння.
УГКЦ має багато парафій за кордоном - в українській діаспорі.
Тож церква завжди обережно ставилася до закликів перейти
на новий календар і орієнтувалася на позицію ПЦУ.
Рішення було, локальні рішення, в окремих країнах, територіях,
щоби переходити на новий календар. І всередині громади ділилися.
Тому що одна частина переходила, вважаючи це доречним,
потрібним і так далі, аргументованою. Інша казала, що у цей спосіб
ми рвемо наш зв'язок з Україною, з матірною землею.
Утім, одна з православних церков в Україні не бажає відмовлятися
від старого календаря. Це УПЦ, яка вважається афілійованою з РПЦ.
Ось що думають про перехід парафіяни цієї церкви.
Як "якого"? 7 січня, звісно! Коли українська церква святкує, тоді і ми.
Яка відзначає вже дві тисячі років. Інші нас не цікавлять.
Мій вік 61 рік. Моя бабуся, моя мама і я все життя святкуємо 7-го.
Так що вибачте, я вже точно переходити не буду.
Я був на святій горі Афон, там ніхто нікуди не переходить, хоча це Греція.
Був у Чорногорії - так само святкують сьомого числа.
Основні слов'яни, які православні, всі 7-го святкують.
Католики - так, у них там свій стиль, я був у Польщі.
Але в нас своє, а в них трошки своє.
Згідно з соцопитуванням групи "Рейтинг", проведеним у червні 2023 року,
третина парафіян УПЦ були проти переходу на новий календар.
Водночас 40 відсотків - підтримали цю ініціативу.
Однак в УПЦ стверджують, що запиту на календарну реформу від вірян немає.
У нас якраз Різдво буде вихідним днем. І все буде нормально.
Тому що 7 січня - це буде недільний день, вихідний день.
І ми всі будемо святкувати так, як і в минулі роки.
Румунська, болгарська, польська й низка так званих "грецьких" православних
церков відзначають Різдво 25 грудня.
А єрусалимська, грузинська, сербська, македонська і російська церкви
дотримуються юліанського календаря.
Ми дотримуємося юліанського календаря так само,
як і Єрусалимська православна церква.
Окрім того, ми знаємо, що така святиня, як гора Афон,
живе за юліанським календарем.
Дуже багато інших православних святинь дотримуються цього календаря.
Тому для нас це і важливо бути із такими центрами православ'я,
які беззаперечні для всіх по всій планеті Земля.
Священнослужителі різних конфесій наголошують - головне не дата, а подія.
Святкування 25 грудня є природнім.
Якщо ми навіть беремо календар, беремо циклічність,
ми побачимо, що саме з 25 грудня наступає на одну хвилину більший день.
Чи це не є таким ще доказом і свідченням того,
що вступає у нову фазу природню світ?
Це ж не є, що Ісус Христос народився саме 7 січня,
чи Ісус Христос народився саме 25 грудня.
Це доволі дискусійні насправді дати. Але хтось,
тобто авторитет церкви зафіксував, що ця дата ось є саме тут.
Саме сьогодні ми святкуємо Різдво. Але завдання головне не є
коли, а йде як.
Наталя, Поля і Ромчик уже знають, як святкуватимуть - у родинному колі.
Згадують рецепт святкових пампухів, репетирують колядки
й загадують найсвітліші побажання.
Сімейні традиції, затишок, коли воно передається з покоління в покоління,
мені здається, це дуже класно і це варто підтримувати і розвивати.
І звісно ж, щоб швидше закінчилася ця війна,
і щоб ця радість була в душі така дійсно…
Наповнювала серце радість, а не смуток, тривога і переживання.
Хай Різдвяна добра казка подарує тепло й ласку,
хай різдвяні світлі зорі знищать смуток весь і горе.
Щастя, радість і добро хай несе до вас Різдво.